of course if you listen to the pundits
we weren't expected to win too much and
our winning winning winning the country
and soon the country is going to start
winning winning winning the only
campaign that has beaten Donald Trump
and the only campaign that can beat
Donald Trump is this campaign so we won
the evangelicals we won with young we
won with old we won with highly educated
we won with poorly educated i love the
poorly educated with the smartest people
with the most loyal people we have a
bunch of fire extinguishers and we are
going to put the fire out and we are
going to put the fire in our bellies if
you were one of the sixty-five percent
of republicans across this country who
doesn't think Donald is the best
candidate to go head to head with
Hillary who believes we do better in
elections when we actually nominate a
conservative then the first four states
have performed a vital function of
narrowing this race and presenting a
clear choice you can choose between to
Washington dealmakers or one proven
consistent conservative and you know
what I really am happy about because
I've been saying it for a long time
forty-six percent with the Hispanics
forty-six percent number one